what do you want try to figure out what
you're not on your zoom class
cause i'm about getting ready to take
your phone i can explain okay i'm not in
my zoom class
because i have nothing to do right a
second i'm sure you got some work you
need to catch up on
i just moved to a new school not too
long ago and
i mean because of this whole corona
thing i have to do
zoom now so now i can't even make no
friends
it's kind of lonely this is fashion
[Music]
you need to start helping me i'm not
your maid i mean i'm 20 years old i
should be out enjoying myself having
lunch with my friends
why are you being so cranky are you on
your lady hood
no josh is coming home today and i would
like the house to look like
we haven't been pig stocked with that
looks terrible
so josh got a construction job in south
carolina three hours away
and then he comes home on the weekends
and it's really taken a toll
with this long distance thing on our
marriage i'm gonna cook dinner tonight
so that we can all sit down as a family
and have a nice family dinner
you mean an arguing fest no
i know pumpkin and josh love each other
but it's like as soon as josh walks
through the door
they start the fussing and hollering
it's kind of like sometimes i'm the only
adult in this house
get out
like i have time for that mama
keeps trying to contact me ever since
she got out of rehab
and i've seen on social media that she's
telling everybody that she's sober but
then again i don't believe her because
you're still with gino so that probably
means still underneath geno's control
and until she gets that out of the way
then she's not really allowed around me
and my family
[Music]
oh you lucky you're cute
you